[Música]
y
solita salteña y crueldad que creen que
puede conectar estas tres imágenes
cuando estaba en búsqueda del sentido de
mi vida profesional me encontré con una
disciplina que me hizo clic al instante
no entendía muy bien de qué se trataba
pero dije esto quiero ser es una
disciplina que mezcla la gastronomía el
diseño y la experiencia del usuario pero
qué es la experiencia del usuario la
experiencia del usuario es diseñar
escenarios para que una experiencia
suceda es crear espacios para descubrir
lo bueno lo útil y lo encantador y la
gastronomía es el arte es la ciencia es
la antropología y la sociología del
cocinar el comer y el servicio
el food experience design busca diseñar
cada detalle para que ese momento sea
único e inolvidable
una de las preguntas que me hago siempre
es cuál es la receta para crear una
buena experiencia
y después de mucho estudiar y obviamente
mucho comer
hoy les voy a presentar los ingredientes
esenciales que para mí son buenos para
que ustedes creen diseñen o coman una
experiencia
ingrediente número 1 la historia yo soy
comunicadora social y desde el día 1 de
mi carrera me enseñaron que todo
comunica todo transmite una idea todo
cuenta una historia volvamos a las tres
imágenes del principio
la cholita la salteña y la crueldad esta
experiencia nació en un taller que yo
doy en la universidad donde los
participantes debían contar una leyenda
urbana boliviana y transmitirla en un
plato
ellos contaron la leyenda urbana de la
cholita martina o la cruel martina
cuenta la leyenda de una cholita de
cochabamba bolivia
que como venganza por los maltratos que
había sufrido cocina a su propio bebé y
además se los da de comer a quienes la
habían maltratado
el plato consiste en una salteña en
forma de bebé rellena de un jugo de rojo
intenso elaborado de una y colorado
y presentado únicamente con un
gigantesco cuchillo de cocina para que
tú des artistes al bebé
varían
se lo comerían
y más importante sentirían esa crueldad
en carne y hueso
no se preocupen que solamente hicimos
prototipos
debo admitir que esta experiencia fue un
poco distinta pero queda claro que si no
hubiésemos conocido la historia no nos
hubiese dado tanto miedo en hacerle daño
a una simple salteña
es que la comida comunica comunica
historias comunica cultura comunica
tradiciones de nuestros pueblos a través
de sus ingredientes sus técnicas y hasta
la forma en cómo nosotros comemos
ingrediente número 2
usar los cinco sentidos
sin soplín un diseñador industrial al
cual yo admiro mucho una vez dijo que lo
que hace el diseño de un producto genial
es por lo menos agregarle un sentido más
el diseño no solamente tiene que ser
visual porque no agregarle texturas
olores sabores esto hará que la
experiencia florezca y se potencie
quiero hacer un experimento con ustedes
este experimento yo llamo razón sónica
quiero que estén muy presentes y con sus
cinco sentidos cuando vean este video
[Música]
pudieron sentir esa cremosidad ese sabor
dulce de un postre además creo que todos
nosotros nos hemos emocionado no es
verdad el food experience design
justamente busca es que al momento de
servir o recibir un plato tú lo puedas
sentir lo puedas poner lo puedas
degustar y vivir una experiencia
sensorial realmente única y qué emoción
es lo que nos lleva a nuestro tercer
ingrediente las emociones
cuál es mi momento favorito
siete de la noche calor infernal
reuniones interminables
salir del trabajo
esta belleza espere
esto sí es
a
pero que sabe la felicidad o la tristeza
o la crueldad
como les conté yo soy comunicadora
social enfocada al diseño de
experiencias gastronómicas y cuando
estoy diseñando experiencias parto de
las emociones que quisiera que las
personas ciento volvamos a la cholita y
a la salten cuando unos estudiantes
conocieron la leyenda y vieron el plato
muchos de ellos me dijeron que se re
usarían en comer este plato ellos han
imaginado a la cholita se han imaginado
al bebé y han sentido esa angustia y ese
dolor yo no quería deprimir ni mucho
menos asustar a mis estudiantes pero
queda claro que contando una historia y
transmitiendo sus sentidos y sus
emociones
podemos vivir una experiencia única
cuando comemos un plato
estos ingredientes no serían posibles
sin ser transmitidos a través del diseño
que es nuestro cuarto ingrediente
cuántos de nosotros cuando vemos algo
que nos encanta al instante sentimos ese
algo que dice tengo que tener con muchas
veces sin siquiera haberlo tocado ya
veces sin siquiera saber para qué sirve
pues hemos hablado de las emociones pero
como es diseñar para las emociones
aunque parezca muy obvio y muy normal
ese plato redondo hondo para conservar
más tiempo la temperatura en realidad es
para sentir eso reconfortante de una
sopita caliente pues la copa de cristal
que es ancha por debajo y fina por
arriba es para poder sentir los aromas
de los frutos rojos ese amor de un
cabernet sauvignon o incluso ese mantel
afelpado para que ningún sonido salga de
su lugar hasta lo más simple y cotidiano
como el cuchillo la cuchara y el tenedor
tuvieron que pasar por una prueba y
error hace miles de años para
perfeccionar su diseño y hacerlo útil
para el disfrute de cada alimento
lo cierto es que el diseño va más allá
de la funcionalidad de la vajilla de los
cubiertos de la silla de la mesa en
realidad es como nosotros interpretamos
ese diseño y le damos funcionalidad
según nuestra cultura nuestra historia y
nuestras vivencias
lo que nos lleva a nuestro quinto
ingrediente y el más importante romper
las reglas
en un mundo donde el protocolo y la
etiqueta nos marcan los pasos de la
comida el food expiring design te invita
a romper las reglas busca que vivas una
experiencia que te desafíe que te haga
repensar la comida a través del diseño y
te haga analizar por qué comes con quién
estás comiendo en qué momento del día
estás comiendo qué historia hay detrás
de lo que estás comiendo ya sea que te
hagas reír te haga llorar o te haga
sentir miedo o curiosidad el objetivo
final es ese que te emociones y vivas
esas sensaciones que hagan que ese
momento sea único
yo los invito a que ustedes diseñen su
propia receta para crear o comer una
experiencia única y memorable
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]